[Music]
you never know who you're gonna see they
have a hospitality tent and the donuts I
send them loose like little kids on the
mall when they're done with the show and
then all of a sudden they're trying to
get free food and next thing I know I'm
getting a text we ran into The Bachelor
the host of The Bachelor exclamation
point exclamation point can we have him
on the show
McLovin can we have him on the show I
said if you want to have Chris Harrison
on the show we can have Chris on the
show so the host of The Bachelor Chris
Harrison two guys joining us what is the
reaction on the street number one
overall reaction that you get no matter
where you are usually it's recognition
the I think I know that guy I think I
maybe went to prom with him I don't know
made out in the back of the Honda Civic
but then it's like oh that's right and
then then inevitably if you're out here
you know with the gallery you get you
know one of the calls of rose guy hey is
this the most dramatic golf usuall
but do you get guys who act like they
don't watch The Bachelor used to it's
it's now it's cooled it's you know what
I think it was the the likes of Jimmy
Kimmel Howard Stern all those guys have
brought everybody out of the closet it's
okay now for a guy a fleet whatever to
be a loud proud member of bachelor
nation but for a while yeah everybody
was you know look I don't watch my wife
watch the show and then an hour and a
half later they stop talking about the
show they say but it's always the guys
that are big fans how did you get the
job oddly enough I did less to get this
job than probably when I was a waiter at
Olive Garden in college I did more to
get that job I was a sportscaster
I started in Oklahoma City as a
sportscaster out of college and then I
actually moved to LA to start up a
horse-racing Network which we did do and
then started I was so naive and so green
when I moved out to LA just started
auditioning did some other stuff and
then The Bachelor though I never
auditioned for just had a meeting met
Mike Fleiss the creator of the show we
hated each other
worst meeting no true story worst
meeting I've ever had in my life my
agent said look you know you need to go
be per be prepared for this really long
you know process and get to know these
people and I went in and I was you know
from from from the Midwest I came out of
you know Oklahoma City and my hair's
parted and I got my suit and tie on
ready for a job interview he came out
californee guy bored show
it's black you know sure his you know
who knows what was in the air that day
in his office and we just didn't get
along and we left is like I hate you I
hate you and that was it two weeks later
got a call back he walked in and he said
Harrison I won't say it on the air but
that was the worst meeting I've ever had
in my life let's do this again I hear a
good guy and we've been best friends
ever since
when did you know that it exploded
Arenberg ii so season two we did season
1 is spring of 2002 and ABC was in the
dumps back then it was you know last
place Network things weren't going well
we did well but it wasn't like
gangbusters and then we had this summer
and it just caught fire and it was just
it was different you could just tell
things were different than when Aaron
Berger he came on and one of the - one
of the things that really stuck out to
me I'll never forget it was I read my
Sports Illustrated and it was sign of
the apocalypse and it was that The
Bachelor outdrew the World Series and
I'm like I think we made it and it was
cousin it was like New York the in the
New York Times and on Time magazine it
wasn't the tabloids and it was it was
just kind of everywhere and it was
something I had never he was my first
Network show he was so much bigger than
me I the way I the best analogy is
making it to the Super Bowl your rookie
year it's fun but you cannot appreciate
it you have no you have no perspective
of what's happening to your life and so
my life was blowing up or on the number
one show there's 33 million people
watching but I don't know what that
means yeah it's like this is great
Jordan Rogers goes on Aaron Rodgers
brother he did I didn't know that that
was Aaron Rodgers brother yeah but when
you when you realize you got something a
little bit different here and now this
is going to impact impact somebody's
life right not on the show like how much
trepidation or concern or caution do you
show when you know you have something
here and the other person can't answer
and you know his brother yeah well with
it with Aaron in particular I'm glad I'm
not in the editing process because I
would I would probably have a little
stronger say about stuff like that
because it was it was that was when I
was taking it out well here's the
where's
weird story I met Aaron on the golf
course oddly enough like several weeks
before we started taping not knowing
that Jordan was gonna be on the show had
no idea and Aaron and I had met he's a
great guy you guys have met him super
super good guy and yeah I mean it's it's
tough vo for a guy speaking personally
who's had his dirty laundry going
through my divorce having no you know
have to deal with that in the public eye
there is that fine line and but you know
Jordan really did want to speak of it I
will say this I think we handled it as
well as we could because Jordan if you
watched the show didn't trash his
brother he did you know it was more of
like just the pain of I wish we could
mend these fences I wish we could fix it
and I was ok with that um you know if it
was trashing Aaron and really back in
the bus over him but it was really just
we had you had to tell the rest of this
story and you couldn't have this happen
with his family and not mention it
somehow I think it would just would have
been a glaring omission sigh I think we
handled it delicately and I think we
handled it well and I've seen Aaron here
this week and he didn't punch me in the
face
did he say anything no we didn't talk
about the show we just thought he just
gave me a hug and said how you doing and
we you know it was the elephant in the
room I didn't know it's the first time
I've seen him since the show aired I
didn't know if he was gonna punch me in
the face I did it here you know in the
in the players Center where there
weren't going to be any cameras because
I know that would have been a big
tabloid but a punch to the face is great
publicity I would have been fine with it
yeah I mean come on I know all about
ratings there's always that side of me
as a producer that day I'm fine I would
have said you know somebody taped this
but don't you know Olivia Munn his
girlfriend I do
oddly enough so Olivia this is such a
small world I was a sportscaster in
Oklahoma City with the CBS affiliate
there and Olivia interned there and I
kind of ran her internship and then when
she moved out to LA I was then married
she actually stayed with us for a little
bit and while she was getting her start
as an actress she came out of Oklahoma
City yeah went away
Erin kind of oh yeah good luck with so
there's that yeah good luck with that
if these guys were single now you be in
the host and they were bachelors let's
say they were on The Bachelorette right
so this would be our last season on TV
yes
but it would it would be it would be
every man who would be on there not
good-looking guys so out of that for the
group for who the core for who do you
think would be the one who gets gets a
rose let's go down murderers row here so
Pauly at the end yeah and then shetan
and then Posse and mclubbe yeah Pauly
acting like he doesn't care seaton given
given me the smoldering look you'll I'm
really turning it on right now
a little bit Nick you know he's giving
me a kind of the Ryan Gosling smoldering
thing mmm man but trying a little too
hard okay yeah yeah what about fritzy
you know stalker I mean McLovin just
seems like such a fit because we talked
yesterday
that's your audience and by the way the
new cool he put out here with the divot
there I don't think pebble wanted to
pull there but he's never gonna be a
professional golf no no no he's now but
McLovin I mean come on that sells it so
it would women be a truck could be you'd
be surprised though Chris let the Hat is
I am not looking good
no the hats not good the hats not
working so it's tag like group date we
gotta get in the hot tub with five women
how are you gonna be well I'd be the one
wearing a t-shirt I'd be the only
interested in personality more than
looks and which doesn't happen often and
we get to the fantasy suite yeah we can
yeah but you if you were single as what
he's saying
a moment that you've had to edit out
that was just too too hot too heavy
oh yeah oh yeah we've mean look it's
still on ABC yeah and so you know this
wasn't let's say it's on HBO
how crazy wouldn't be odd we could I
mean you could really go as deep and
dark as you want
yeah with with things that are said you
know off-color remarks and jokes and and
you know between the language between
the nudity between I mean you could we
could do it pretty incredible and what's
the that's law after dark would be an
amazing show what's the goofy girl's
name Corral Corinne yeah yeah but she's
good for TV she's great yeah I mean look
it you know people always think that we
cast the crazy girl crowd you really
don't you don't have to I mean look
right here yeah I was gonna say half but
a hundred percent of this group are
crazy you lock down this stage and we
have a show right here these guys you
know a few are gonna be in tears before
the end of the day really yeah easily
that emotional that sounds like your
show no but people think we go out of
our way to find that you don't have to
you know that stuff really does come on
its own he's Chris Harrison host of The
Bachelor we love to have you on again
it was great love it you guys have been
such a fan of the show I know you guys
talked about the show and and then when
I saw these guys yesterday I'm like oh
they of all the people we've had on this
week they're all the sudden we ran into
Chris Harrison host at badger can he be
on I'm like like a little kids asking if
they could have dessert for me I've been
here all week too and been doing stuff
with the PGA and the did a deal for the
players why it's like fantasy camp here
for me I mean you know these guys Jim
Nantz was just here no no hello friends
yes McLovin can i pepper him with
questions about Nick no no you can't
okay now it's time we got around after
you can walk him back to the hospitality
suite if you want to okay as they take
him take a moment say my goodbyes you
can walk me to the limo wow you can give
him a rose he's Chris Harrison host of
The Bachelor thank you Chris we'll be
back the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]